[Music]
jonathan is in houston texas hey
jonathan welcome to the ramsay show
thank you to the both of you it's a good
afternoon afternoon how can we
help yes sir so recently uh my wife and
i just got married back in december
which is great
and to give you some context we have
a uh we are both got free we have a
fully funded emergency fund and we're
following the baby steps which is great
and we live without and live with my
parents
so as you can see we are motivated by
home
and we are wanting to stick within the
parameters that you provide being the
fifteenth fixed and the fourth of our
take home and we are looking around but
we find ourselves not finding a home
that fits our needs so we've inquired
about a grant that's being offered here
in houston area and with me being an
employee of the national bank that comes
along with some perks but even with all
that stuff
we're still not finding ourselves with a
home that we felt really want to fall in
love with and make and make that big
purchase how old are you so my question
to you is what should we do how old are
i am
i am 26 and my wife is 20 high
and what's your household income
uh gross is about 120.
okay
um
and how much do you have saved for a
down payment
uh not much again we have a fully funded
emergency fund i would say maybe after
that i would have
uh just under 10 grand possibly
so we wouldn't have enough for a 20 down
payment maybe not even 10
and like i said we are living with our
parents in the meantime
yeah i got you and you got and you just
got married the other day
uh december of last year yesterday
december 14th yeah like two weeks ago
yeah something like that yeah all right
just making sure i know which december
okay all right um
i don't know that it matters but i'm
just curious okay so
uh
well george you can chime in you you
just got married what would you do i
mean you got married a couple years ago
right yeah i would if if this is gonna
be a year or two away i'm gonna move out
and rent somewhere that's my that's my
take um that's just gonna give me a
feeling like i'm actually married and
like an adult and stuff and if it's a
real short period of time and you guys
need this it's okay but i don't think a
long-term plan is um to live with the
parents so how fast could you save up 20
on a house that you guys like cause i
heard you say fall in love with and it
feels like you're looking for this
forever home and the truth is it's just
a box
and find something that suits your needs
that you really really need but you
don't need to find this dream home right
now at 26 newly married
got it well one of the things with the
grant that we're getting is that we have
to stay in the home for five years and
we kind of whoa whoa whoa stop stop stop
stop stop stop what kind of grant
it's a granted scheme provided here for
houston residents it's a first time home
buyer
correct it's a fifteen thousand dollar
grant i'll pass and it doesn't affect
i'm sorry i'll pass no thank you
okay all right then well anyway you know
why we're still obviously you know why
because you got to live in the house
five years
you're 26 years old you've been married
20 minutes
it's impossible for you to plan exactly
what's going to happen for five years
for a lousy 15 grand you make 120 you're
gonna let these people control your life
no thank you
the tail's wagging the dog man so i'm if
i'm you i'm looking for an apartment
right now
get a cheap apartment and save money for
a year
and like a crazy person set up your life
and and then go make your down payment
on your house the truth is there's no
rule that says you have to own a house
as soon as you get married and i know
you guys feel like well this is going to
make us feel like adults but right now
you're living with your parents so go
rent for a year figure out what area you
want to live in what house you want and
be diligent about saving up that down
payment i want you guys to save up 20
and avoid the pmi and you know the
parameters so you're going to follow
that and that's going to really help you
guys get on the right foot with this
marriage even if that's two years from
now i'm okay with you renting for two
years if it means getting into a house
the right way yeah
so guys let me just tell you we work
with there's a lot of government grant
things out there
and uh there are a few
times that a government grant
has
a few enough strings attached to it
that it's okay to take it but when we
hear government grant all of us
initially until you've had a bad
experience or two with them
uh
me uh until you've had that experience
you you would say oh it's just free
money
but it's free money that comes with
handcuffs
and shackles the dumbest one i ever got
involved with was i was doing
renovations in my 20s when i was buying
houses buying selling houses and i
bought a historic house
in a historic area one of these
re-gentrified areas we're going to
you know turn the hood into a
neighborhood again that kind of thing
and the beautiful old home beautiful
home and there was a historic grant
available
from the hysteric society
i mean the historic society
i thought you got that one wrong but i
realized it was and it was five thousand
dollars which in in the in in 1980s 5000
was some money it was more than 15 000
right
and so
but the grant stipulated that the house
had been put back
the way it was originally built to be
historically accurate
great that's what i was planning to do
anyway
then codes comes along and says you have
to put a rail on the front porch
because since this house was built we
figured out people fall off the front
porches and break their face
so you cannot have a front porch this
high without without a thing and i said
great go tell the hysteric society that
you're requiring this
and i could not get these two
government people that was nice i was
try i cleaned that up that was
considerable on the fly these two
government people to come into agreement
and in alignment because i didn't care
whether i put a rail up or not i just
wanted to free five thousand dollars
i spent so much time and energy i
finally just told them stick it put the
rail on the porch and said i don't need
your hysteric society money and
you guys are nuts
you're requiring something that the law
doesn't allow in order to give a grant
now that's just asinine
but that's pretty typical when you get
involved in government grants and you're
gonna get your foot caught in the golden
handcuffs or your ear
or your neck
or something when you're screwing with
these dadgum grants and occasionally
there's one that doesn't have enough
nooses built onto it that it's worth
screwing worth doing but man i'll tell
you what we've looked at them in
business we've looked at a minute
remember ppp loans oh yeah yeah there's
a grant wasn't it no it wasn't it was a
loan
and some of you are paying that puppy
back now after we told you not to take
it
and everybody got real quiet about that
whole subject didn't they nobody talking
about that much
but we were yelling and screaming in the
microphone not to take that that they
were going to grab you guys around the
throat and that's exactly what's
happened to a bunch of you business
people out there yeah you now have a big
butt federal loan
so the lesson is uh if it has an if or a
butt attached to it it's a government
but that's what it is yeah the if the
govern if someone says i'm from the
scariest words in the english language
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help
yeah that's that's that's scary language
right there that should scare the pea
wadden out of you man
so enough me railing on the poor young
guy he's just trying to get a house but
i'm not picking on you jonathan you're a
good man congratulations on your
marriage go get you an apartment save
you some money buy a house son
don't don't try to trick your way into
this and for god's sakes george is right
there a stupid house there's one on
every corner get you a house that you
like but there's no such thing as a
forever home because your forever
changes
you're forever changing
you know you had a forever home until
you got two dogs now it's not a forever
home anymore then we got three kids oh
my god it's for sure not a forever home
and then we're gonna move again into a
bigger house and call that our forever
home but it's not really you for never
home because your your your life changes
and goes through seasons so you're going
to go through seasons of change with
your with your house that's just
uh
very few people buy a home i mean
statistically it's got to be less than
five percent and stay in it their entire
lives yeah it's just almost no one so
but newlyweds they get starry-eyed about
the home buying process exactly
exactly and we want you to get a house
we just don't want the house to get you
so there you go we certainly don't want
the government to get you